so i'm really excited to be here today
i was an undergraduate and a master's
student here and i see some faces that
were part of that
educational journey in the room and
a lot of the kinds of questions that i
look at in my research might seem
like they're they're really in
conversation
with anthropology and feminism but also
in conversation with my experiences in
computer science and so i'm thrilled to
be able to
come talk to you about this project work
today and try to draw a loop between
those modes of thinking and analyzing
the world that
often are not connected when we go to
kai or we go to an sts conference
so today i'm going to be focusing on how
to
different ways of centering the human in
human computation
i'll be talking pretty much about
mechanical turk as the central example
because that's the work that i've been
doing and that's the example that i know
best but i'm going to argue that
mechanical turk is a way of organizing
workers and programmers and digital data
production
that also tells us some things about
high-tech production
cultures more generally that we can
watch out for as
very elite and privileged participants
in those cultures
and i'll talk about terkopticon as one
intervention in in
into that kind of culture and actually
i'm getting into my overview now
so and after talking about trekkopticon
and some lessons that i learned working
on tricopticon
point out to other ecologies of worker
mobilization
that are happening both in this
department and in the worlds of workers
so uh to start for any of you who don't
know what amazon mechanical turk
is i'll just do a very quick overview so
the basics of amazon mechanical turk is
that it's
a payment processing platform and an
online
digital digital labor market that amazon
has set up so
if you're an engineer and there's a
whole bunch of
images that you have of things people
are uploading say you're going to make
the cute cat
sites and you need to know are these
images actually images of cute cats
are they not cute cats or are they
chairs or are they some kind of
malicious data
you need a way to sort through that
massive data that's come to characterize
web 2.0 systems
but these are the kinds of cultural data
processing tasks that artificial
intelligence tends to be bad at and for
me
to understand why terry winograd's
understanding computers and cognition is
still a fantastic resource
um but the short version of the argument
is that computers don't are not embodied
in the world culturally and socially the
way people are and so how could you
expect a computer to keep up with what a
cute cat is
unless you train his artificial
intelligence algorithm and keep
retraining it to keep up with that
so for this kind of pro data processing
problem
um for example amazon built mechanical
turk as a way of saying well if ai
algorithms have a really hard time doing
these kinds of classifications
we can bring people into the loop
because people are really good at making
those kinds of classifications
sometimes these people actually do the
data processing in real time i believe
linkedin
has people do optical data recognition
of their business cards and then
that's done by mechanical turk workers
and then sometimes these workers
actually create training sets in semi
you know fairly rapidly to then train
machine learning algorithms that can do
larger scale classification but then the
workers can be used to retrain and
update those data
on those uh algorithms so
how is this different from any kind of
like data processing
outsourcing operation i mean we've had a
couple of decades of sending
large amounts of office documents to
places with lower labor costs
with a lot of english skills like india
where people will go and digitize what
people have written in hand on forms and
upload into a system
well one big difference that i'm going
to focus on today
is that amazon mechanical turk actually
organizes all these workers over here
so that they're accessible through and
through apis
through algorithms and through acts of
coding so instead of
going out and finding a business
processing outsourcing center or signing
a contract having that pers
that center having to have a manager
this in some sense uh amazon mechanical
turk in some sense allows programmers to
become managers
through familiar acts of coding
so when mechanical turk mechanical
turret came out i think in 2006
and in 2000 and i think
eight i was in my first second year of
grad school
and the debate it seemed to me like
this was a way of creating a lot of jobs
with no minimum wage and i was a little
bit puzzled that the tech culture that
i'd come from that was so utopian
in aspirations for creating a better
world i worked at google
you know had also produced the system
that produced so many jobs but they seem
to be so low paying
and at the time there's a sort of a
debate of
you know does amt empower workers or
does amt
exploit workers so on the empowerment
side
you had people saying well you know
people are doing this work for fun clay
sharkey's cognitive surplus
was i think about to come out um they're
just killing time and getting paid
instead of paying to play world of
warcraft
or 122 an hour is a good income for
people in developing countries where
the assumption was that a lot of these
workers would be doing this work from
because why would an american do work
for a dollar or two an hour
um as it turns out there are mostly
americans working in these systems but
we'll get to that
also the in some ways mechanical turk
allows workers to work from home to work
from their pajamas they don't have to
pay for gas to get to work and they can
to some extent choose their employers so
there's a sense of freedom that was seen
as part of the platform and this was the
dominant story
in the public and media view
so on the flip side you have the reading
mostly coming from communication
scholars academics
academic marxists but this is completely
exploitative um
one dollar an hour is nothing in
comparison to the potential profits that
are being made
um amazon mechanical turk is taking jobs
that maybe would have offered benefits
or some stability and making them even
more precarious we have to choose a new
employer every couple of days
and this was pretty limited
to academia and very cynical corners of
it
but coming into it as graduate students
my colleagues six silberman and i
are the people who we've been really on
this journey together for the last
six years working on this um it seemed
exploitative to us
but we were not workers working at this
system so it still seemed like an open
question as to what the experiences
uh workers were having in the system
were and whether they experienced them
as exploitative
so i wasn't in a social science class i
was in an art class
and so i put out a non-rigorous
non-social scientific
open-ended survey asking workers if you
could have a turker's bill of rights
what would you want to be in that bill
of rights so i got 67 responses
um 30 35 of the responses complained
were workers complaining about unfair or
arbitrary rejections
so one of the things that amazon did was
to attract employers to
system because there's a really new
technology was give employers a lot of
discretion
about whether the employers had to pay
or not so if employers didn't like
the kind of data work they were
receiving they could say this is low
quality or this is spam
and no questions asked they could refuse
payment but it seemed like a number of
workers felt that they were
getting caught in a trap of overzealous
employers rejecting their work
and they didn't there's no way in the
system for arbitration to happen
um employers don't have to respond to
workers when they complain
um some workers said that they weren't
getting paid quickly enough that
employers would take 30 days to pay them
for a test that only took three minutes
and for ones that were working to make
ends meet or to make money last minute
to sort of make final rent
this payment speed was a real problem um
but that amazon employer seemed
generally unresponsive to workers
concerns because there were way more
workers
it seemed than employers so if
this worker went away then another
worker would come to fill the spot
and a much smaller number but some
complain that there's no minimum wage
but the upshot from this experiment was
actually that
a lot of the things that we assumed
would be a problem like the lack of
minimum wage wasn't the dominant thing
people were complaining about
and there were things that neither the
empowerment or the exploitation side had
thought of
had not thought of that workers
recognize as really salient
immediate problems uh so it was
and it was so as one worker put it the
way amazon had organized the interface
there was a pervasive sense of
unfairness
about what about uh who made the
decisions in the worker employer
relationship
so this worker describes his feelings
this way
i don't care about the penny i didn't
earn for not knowing the difference
between an apple
and a giraffe but i'm angry that
mechanical turk will take a requester's
money
but not manage oversee or mediate the
problems and injustices on their site
so we're seeing here an example of a
worker talking about
a feeling that within this workplace
they generally
don't have power and it's kind of by the
policy and interface designs
even if the actual monetary outcomes of
that imbalance
might be small it's and still bother
them as a matter of fairness
so when we try so when six and i tried
to take these concerns seriously
we started to see that simply enabling
employers to respond to workers
wouldn't necessarily make sense because
the part of the point of mechanical turk
is that an employer
a programmer can hire 60 000 people to
do a bunch of data work
in a couple of days or an academic can
hire a bunch of experimental subjects
and do that and get their data work done
or their experimental subjects
run really quickly so mediation and
arbitration is
fundamentally unscalable the promise of
mechanical turk
is large-scale data labor for small
operators and
nimble actors so as one requester put it
you can't spend time exchanging mail
the time you spent looking at the email
costs more than what you paid them
this has to function on autopilot or as
an algorithmic system
and integrated with your business
processes
so this led us to a broader insight that
really what is powerful about amazon
mechanical turk and i
hinted at this in the beginning is that
mechanical turk makes workers
people into a scalable computational
infrastructure
and what happens when you and this has
been part of the dream from the
beginning
so when jeff bezos launched mechanical
turk
at mit he gave a talk where he had a
little pseudo code snippet
where this is a pseudo code showing how
a mechanical check work could be brought
into an algorithmic loop to do image
processing
so this is the call where you know call
mechanical turk is there a human in the
picture
photo02 and so programmer can code this
up walk away and get 60 000 images
processed you guys are familiar with
this
um and this is
this is actually a picture from the mit
homepage in 2010 it was actually about
michael's work
which is one of the reasons i'm really
thrilled to be working with michael
because he's very
um engaged and interested in having a
critical dialogue and a productive
interventionist dialogue about this but
so mit advertised michael's amazing work
with crowds
by putting a whole bunch of people on a
microchip so this thing
that gets manufactured in large numbers
by dell that we buy that we put in our
houses and has been promised to empower
us
with the powers of computing and
interactive technologies
now you can put workers inside and they
can power
they can power that same uh
computational platform
so one of the things that was
interesting to me was that simply
putting people in a chip
and putting it on a website doesn't make
that narrative make sense to a broad
number of people
but we kept seeing this narrative show
up in different places on the mit
homepage and
jeff bezos launch dialogue when a
mechanical trick came out people said oh
it's like the human api
it's humans as a service so continually
there's this reimagining of
all the power of a coder at a machine
building amazing things but now you can
get people
to power that same computational magic
that we build in departments like
computer science and information science
as well
in social theory and policy um in
western culture where people
tend to take on the character we imagine
those people having the characteristic
of males
so like these are people that are always
on in the processor
and they're not having to run out to
give milk to the child that they just
born they're at home taking
care of for example so yeah i mean the
fact that they're not gendered actually
is
interesting because it sort of assumes
that everyone can be the same in the
processor because they're just producing
data as far as you care
they are the same as long as they
produce data
um so and this is just another example
of a lab at berkeley that is
algorithms machines and people and
they're also doing a lot of data
processing
using this kind of human labor so this
example actually brings me to
some of the political economic forces
that also make micro microlabor really
really
attractive is that as web 2.0 companies
like facebook have become
huge and people are putting more and
more of their social and cultural lives
online
there's a lot of data to moderate
there's a lot of is this porn or is this
a policy violation or is this
web page something we wanted you know
some web user to go to after clicking on
an ad
that is really hard for ai to do and as
and servers are expensive to run so you
need
really accessible large amounts of data
labor to actually process that kind of
cultural data
so one of the points that i've been
building up to is that amazon mechanical
turk isn't just a way of getting lots of
data processed
it isn't just a way of making people
compensate for where ai can't quite
reach yet but it will soon
but actually mechanical turk is about
making innovators
it's a platform that organizes workers
in an easily accessible way so that
people working on a lean startup
so grad students are faculty doing
research experiments who need a lot of
data fast
people who want to make amazing
interactive technologies
can work on soft it can keep working on
the software stack
and use those workers as media so if you
think of
media media is a platform that takes
your inscriptions right
you have paint you have canvases you
have pencils and paper pencils and paper
are not known for fighting back for
being recalcitrant for not taking your
orders
they're meant as strata that promote
human expression
so mechanical turk takes that idea of an
expressive artist and says
hey you can do that and do it on a
factory of 60 000 people producing data
and this also lets employers who don't
know how to be managers who don't know
how to write outsourcing contracts
actually
do this through acts of coding that
they've already learned
and it also one of the things we found
in the with the um
employers we talked to is that it lets
people who see themselves as part of the
creative classes
you know designers journalists
redistribute the tasks that they
consider to be
repetitive or wrote or low value put
those out into the mechanical check
platform
so that someone else can do it and that
these more elite creative class workers
can focus on
more valuable tasks at the end of the
day if you know you're a journalist and
you get all your interviews transcribed
by a mechanical turk worker
your work as a journalist is not
devalued you actually publish more
articles that way and you get more
credit for
in some sense the things that really
matter because the mechanical
transcription work that you got done it
does matter to your project
but getting it done faster and cheaper
only helps you in the way we measure
status in these creative class
professions
so this kind of the other thing that
interface layer
that mediates between employers and
workers does is also mediate doubt
so in high-tech cultures i mean we have
a long tradition of computer
professionals for social responsibility
for places like google really caring
about information becoming accessible
because
they believe information helps people
amazon mechanical turk make puts the
workers so far away that you it's really
hard to figure out what conditions
workers are working under
even if you do care so people can think
things like well people are mostly doing
it for fun and
you can't coerce someone through a
screen
i'm arguing that this mediated doubt is
actually something that's very powerful
in making mechanical trick
take off among really well-meaning
programmers and engineers
so putting those two things together
the argument here is that mechanical
turk makes labor
invisible in a way that sustains the
myths of peer production in high tech
so for me this came like i
was really struck by a story a designer
told me that i met in india
he was talking about making a system
that processes
processes uh web webcam images of
traffic in different intersections in
african city and he said well we have a
bunch of low paid workers in the design
studio
that are processing these images and
making them into data so that we can
have this
mobile app that lets commuters figure
out which streets to avoid
but it's kind of awkward having such
different
kinds of workers in the same studio
because so much of
how we talk about creating spaces of
innovation is about creating space it's
a flow
of comfort of play of quick and easy
interdisciplinary sharing
so having lower status data processing
workers in that space
was a problem for him and he said oh
maybe mechanical turk can help me solve
that problem
so i'm emphasizing this because i think
this is one way that what mechanical
turk represents is actually a feature
of innovation culture more broadly in
some of the ways that
say janitors don't get paid very much
because they get hired through many
levels of subcontractors but that
kind of wage structure is hidden from
workers who are well-meaning but work in
these large tech companies
um okay so this is how this is kind of
how far we got with
our analysis but the question was how to
proceed
um workers on mechanical turk had a
really different range of problems
some of them wanted unions some of them
said no unions no way i want to be a
freelancer and so we tried to identify
places where workers did agree that they
had some kind of common issue yeah
gilbert
don't pay attention if this is too much
of a digression but
when you mentioned uh in particular that
uh
this mediated doubt um
i'm wondering if that is something
particularly different about that from
just
alienation of workers um
alienation workers in a marxist sense of
separating someone from their means from
their things that they're
producing well that as well as uh
alienation
from their the managers in this case
hmm um
this is the first time someone sees the
whiteboard during a talk
that's in the back of the room
okay um i think that's a really good
question but i
i'm a little worried i just want to make
sure to get through trekkopticon as an
example and then come back to it so
um so in figuring out where to proceed
we didn't want to side with the
empowerment or the exploitation
we wanted to figure out a project that
would let us
meet workers where they're telling us
they are
at the same time as somewhat improving
their conditions
and provoking a debate about ethics in
human computation that we felt like
wasn't happening in human computer
action ai and the media so
that brings me to the main uh project
that michael was talking about
which is called tricopticon um which we
built to interrupt invisibility and
support mutual aid among workers and
mechanical turk and that's the work that
i've been doing with six
silverman as well as there's three
mechanical turk workers who are
moderators
uh tainter khanwan and minwinter and
also workers who write all the reviews
that make cherkopticon at all meaningful
so i'll tell you a little bit about what
that work has been
so terkopticon is an attempt to take
this
configuration that makes workers
invisible and reconfigure
those optics so what it does is it lets
workers in mechanical turk review
employers
and so we have a website there's a
database that contains the reviews
they're matched to requester ids
and there's also firefox and chrome
tools
that workers can install so as they're
browsing mechanical turk tasks
we insert a button next to each
mechanical turk requester
pulling up any reviews we have for that
id and
we insert them in the page where the
worker will be making the decision
about who to work for so
what we ask for in the reviews are four
categories
that we got from talking from reading
those mechanical turk
bills of rights responses it seemed like
a lot of workers complained about
communicativity of the employer the
generosity of the employer and wages
the fairness of the employer you know
does the employer respond when there's
been a mistake
um and promptness how quickly does the
employer pay
so within that we
have workers rate on each of those
categories on a scale of one to five
and then we encourage workers so this is
over here on the trichopticon website
we encourage workers to also write
open-ended comments explaining their
interpretations yeah do you have a
question
okay um so we ask workers to quantify
not because we think that these
particular qualities are readily uh
quantifiable it's actually really
how do you quantify generosity if you
are
you have different sets of workers who
need vastly amounts of vastly different
amounts of money to live
but because mechanical turk workers are
working in such a fast
production culture they're choosing
among many employers
they have a lot of judgments to make
they're choosing employers every
day maybe even every couple of hours so
expecting them to pour through
open-ended reviews just seems sort of
unrealistic so
the numbers say well if this employer
has really good numbers then go ahead
and work for them but if it's some if
it's anything more ambiguous then
we really wanted there to be a more
interpretive archive of what makes this
worker good or bad
and so that tool on this
and that website this is the home page
for it so it's more than just
functional it's more than just a way of
evening the information playing field
it was actually meant to use design as
an intervention into the politics
around crowdsourcing so drawing from
carl de salvo's work
at georgia tech our homepage is
deliberately agonistic
so agonistic democracy is the idea that
rather than working towards consensus
democracies function better when you
encourage people to
produce strong positions in which
different points of view different
experiences different information can
come out
so this home page was meant to provoke a
response promote work
you know we have a classified ad up here
help wanted 120 an hour risk of
repetitive stress injury
no care for on the job injuries no
guaranteed minimum wage mechanical turk
industries
and the purpose of that it wasn't that
we thought that people were going to
believe us we knew that
people have lots of different opinions
we wanted to provoke the debate
so we were using design not only just to
make something usable but also to make
something
that provokes a set of discourses around
it
so within that um we've been fairly
successful
successful in serving
uh serving some needs of workers in the
mechanical turk workforce
uh we have our usage has grown
we have 20 i guess something like 20 000
unique visitors
um but i don't want to present this as
an unalloyed success like this is not
enough to actually claim
impact um so on the one hand
turkopticon enables workers to aid one
another on the other hand there are
problems so
in some sense and church opticon sorry
i meant to say trekkopticon enables
workers to aid one another but
tricopticon also in some sense
legitimizes amazon mechanical turk like
what if some competitor
that had better labor practices could
come along and replace mechanical turk
and trekkopticon is actually making it
harder for that competitor to break
through
i also learned from mary gray in
microsoft research who's doing work on
crowdsourcing that
a lot of workers who are in india find
turkopticon and other american-run
worker forums
to be inhospitable places because a lot
of workers diagnosing the low wages and
mechanical turk will say oh it's because
workers from these other countries will
work for anything and that's our problem
and so while that might relief
relieve stress or be one theory
indian workers stay away and mary was
saying they share information in other
formats
on the web so
i want to i'm taking uh i'm making an
effort to present this as ambivalent
because i think a lot of times in design
we talk about coming up with solutions
and improving and here it's very clear
that there's an intervention and it
certainly changes the conditions of
reality
but it all depends on what perspective
you take whether it's for the better or
for the worse but at least it's
different than what it was six years ago
so i wanted to conclude by pointing out
to other
kinds of horizons and ecologies of
workers
engaging in mutual aid and trying to
improve conditions
in within crowd work and i'll explain a
little bit about why
um so one of the really
important places where workers talk with
one another and it's been like this for
six years at least
our forums like turker nation cloudme
baby
and these are forums that are operated
by workers
where workers can share information with
one another
they can you know people pray for each
other when they're having bad weeks
people and each other money
nilufar discovered through some of her
work in newfarsal
here who i'm collaborating with um
and workers will take really stable
kinds of computational infrastructure
like php-based forums put them on a
server
and then use this to their own ends and
the communities
that get built here the discussions that
get built here affect
the ability people have then
intracopticon workers have intercopticon
to
talk with one another resolve disputes
or sometimes fights spill over
from here into turkopticon so turkoff
taking the design of charcoticon alone
doesn't explain the social dynamics of
cherkovtikon because chircaptacon
exists as one place that people from
these forums pass through
also emergent turker tactics that come
out of workers talking with one another
in these forums and on church opticons
so
more receptive requesters or employers
will come to these forums and ask
workers why isn't anyone doing my task
or why are you guys giving me such
horrible reviews and how can i fix it
so these forums make possible some of
that negotiation
at a larger scale than email
interactions for requesters that
actually want to be fair
but where email was an inadequate way of
promoting that kind of problem
supporting that problem resolution um
anecdotally i've actually heard a number
of workers talk about holding out for a
minimum pay rate of six dollars an hour
which as i understand it is coming out
of just conversations in these forums
and they
have a really hard time enforcing that
pay rate because you can't have a it's
hard to have a boycott when a lot of
workers
desperately need the money but it's an
emergent tactic and it'll be interesting
to see what happens with it
some workers actually use the irb the
institutional
ethics review boards that universities
have to have
to hold employers who are academic
researchers accountable
so if a researcher runs an experiment
and doesn't pay
there's a one worker in new zealand and
one of our moderators who seems to take
a thrill out of calling the irb
and using that institutional mechanism
to
to call those employers to account so
that was one of the favorite things i'd
ever heard about irp
and i mentioned that nilufar found yeah
that's actually an excellent tactic
because
unlike if i were to complain to say like
linkedin
if you don't approve like if they're
having problems linkedin the irb
will cut like that's actually a higher
power that would go to talk to this
individual
so that's a really adaptively
intelligent strategy yeah
yeah as well as the potential
consequences are a lot higher
yeah yeah
the reason i'm highlighting these kind
of emergent worker tactics
and these web-based forums is because i
think that
we need to value them the way that
you're valuing them um
and they tend to not be valued so one of
the experiences that we had with
trekopticon
was that journalists who wanted to say
oh mechanical turk is a digital
sweatshop would then come to tricopticon
and say
oh look techies caused this problem
techies are solving this problem
thank goodness we have smart people
working on this and workers who are
reading these news articles will say
these articles cast us as dopes that
we're just
you know being engineered through these
different platforms and we have saviors
coming in
to tell us what we need to help
ourselves um
so to me that was a real lesson that
when we do these design interventions
to improve people's lives no matter how
much on the ground work
is necessary to actually make that
design intervention sustain and have
life
we tend to focus on the software authors
or the authors of the design
interventions
to credit them as the heroes or the
entrepreneurs that
instigated this change not only is that
bad social analysis in this case it's
also really bad for politics because it
creates a
it created a lot of um it basically
insulted
it it basically insulted the very
workers that it thought to describe
and the possibility of moving forward in
a more collaborative way
so that's why i'm taking it
not making an effort here to focus on
some of these
things that don't look like writing new
algorithms or making new mechanisms
or making something that will be
recognizable as inventive intellectual
property
but has been sustained and innovative
so to conclude so one of the the third
project and this is where i'll conclude
is work that
neelu fire is leading and michael and i
are supporting which is
actually i'll just skip ahead um it's
called crowdflash and so in brief
crowdflash builds on
the insight that a worker had during
some interviews i did at irvine
where he said this guy this worker had
done labor organizing
um sky nick he lives in ithaca and he
the interviewer was an undergrad i was
working with andreas asked him
you know have you thought about trying
to organize people online and he said
well i thought about it
but the community is so like loose that
i don't even know where i really begin
with that
i could go to all the forums and they
would say that's a great idea we should
do that and then
you know where's it going to go from
there and we did see examples of workers
saying hey let's do a petition or let's
do some public action in forums
where some people said yes this is a
great idea and then it just sort of
petered out
so nilufa's work is geared towards
giving workers a way of finding common
issues developing action plans and then
giving them the kind of social media
social computing support to actually act
on that
and motivate people to kind of
participate all along the way and so
hopefully she'll get to give a talk
about this at some point
so um in conclusion uh what i've argued
here is that
making humans into computing
infrastructure it expands the agency
that we have as programmers with the
skills that we get
while sustaining the myth of peer
production but it does it by sort of
externalizing
the labor that's actually necessary to
making digital technologies
possible um terkopticon was one attempt
to interrupt that
invisibility and is a platform for
mutual aid but
it's definitely not enough we so we want
to take that kind of mutual aid in that
community that we've been part of
producing along with other worker run
forums
and continue participating in this
ecology
of of giving workers the ability to hold
employers and hold amazon
more accountable to pressure for changes
that would make their work conditions
better
so with that maybe else get questions or
address gilbert's question
thank you very much
so should i try to start with your
question um i'm really not trying to i'm
not a question of waiter um
so your question was
was about whether a mechanical check
produces alienation between workers and
their managers
well i guess you you mentioned sort of
the this mediated doubt as something
that sounded somewhat
new and i was wondering what
what exactly is new there compared to
just alienation
from for instance outsourcing already
or oh i see i think for me
mediated doubt is so the outs there's
lots of ways that people
either have gaps in empathy or
understanding
or that the structures
of needing to produce profitable
businesses or to produce more academic
papers
also make it possible for people to kind
of self inter interestedly ignore
dimensions of the kinds of social
relations they need
to push on other people to get that work
done right so that's a very old story i
think for me mediated doubt
is just the extra layer of okay wait but
if you have this community that
is very publicly committed to
um producing progress
through the work they're doing like a
mckinsey consultant
historically doesn't say oh i'm gonna
make the world a better place by
figuring out better ways of doing
mergers and acquisitions and gaining
efficiencies
or private equity or outsourcing
companies but
here we have an industry where people
actually are invested in that kind of
progress through the work they do and
yet still um
uh this interface layer making humans
sit behind an api
sort of helps mitigate some of the
tensions of the vast inequality that
actually is being produced here
so i think that's the only incremental
bit that's different
so for me the principal component of
this seems to be that amazon
created a broken system and look
whatever how everything breaks after
that
right so if thank god for their third
parties
well i mean things like forums right
where we are
essentially organizing for public action
against
a private employer right and to me
the question then is
in order to do it better right and i
asked this because when we started doing
the peer assessment
in large classes uh when i hear scott's
class anyone
would send this email and say hey my
grade was unfair
uh look at this and he said he couldn't
we would you wanted and we would give
them the data
it was up there and i i met someone else
from a different class some
weeks ago and they're like we just can't
deal with the retail requests so to be
fair to everybody
we don't deal with any of them right
and it seems
a lot of potential for things to go
wrong so i'm wondering if you have any
ideas
how to design things into the system so
they don't that's a really good question
um one of the things that i've been
startled by the more i think about this
um and the more moocs become something
that
you know are part of public
consciousness and
you know i'm teaching in a university of
california institution now which has
kind of like been doing learning at
scale
for a while is how similar some of the
problems actually are
um
i mean i think at the end of the day one
of the lessons for me is that you can't
actu
you can design some things into the
system and that's why i'm really glad to
be working with you michael and nilufa
and sixx
has been thinking about how would you
design a system that makes um
that changes the economic incentives
that requesters have for the ways that
they behave
but also is within that you're also
within
say with mechanical turk in the social
structure where you know companies need
to make profits or promise profits in
order to get investments
and so it still remains profitable to
outsource work that's less valued in a
market
economy um to people who can do it
and uh that you know so and to own the
means of that production so like
economic at some level economic
structure
is also a question here
which is different than the case in a
sense as well but
i think people are not complaining about
the economic incentives they're
complaining about fairness
more or less right well they're going to
have the economics
will not work for a lot of the new
employers or the notoriously low
paying employers like linkedin is
notorious for paying very little to its
workers
and the only reason workers go
kind of my ethnographic sense is that
the only reason workers will do linkedin
tasks is if their approval rating goes
down because they've
had a huge rejection they have to get it
back up so they can get access to the
good jobs again
or that they're new and they don't have
access to the good jobs so
the wages the wages really are an issue
but that was more
in 2006 when i was writing um
when i was doing the bill of rights the
fairness was sort of the issue that cut
across
and the wages were a little bit more
like depending on where you're living
were more or less of an issue but i
think to your question how would you
design it differently
i don't think i don't know that you can
have human computation
as um as a cheap
platform without
still having these problems because if
you want to have an api
that is served by humans and you want it
to be cheap
i mean how you know people are doing
this
people are doing this because they need
the money in many cases
we don't have updated data but in 2010
it was 20
of people needed it to sometimes or
always make ends meet and that was
before the economic crisis
and now most of the workers who are
doing this are in the united states
because international workers are
considered to be too spammy and so
they're only given permission to do this
work on a very small
uh on a very narrow basis so
yeah like is it cheap fast or ethical
you know you can only pick two i guess
yeah oh yeah
what is the breakdown of um like the
battery questions because like you can
imagine
there's of course like the typical
example of like something like linkedin
large corporation trying to
optimize the profits but there's also
the other one where like a person
is actually intending to be a bad
requester they're just like
kind of careless like they underestimate
the amount of time that requires to take
a task or the new mechanical turret and
all that like
um do they like constitute a significant
portion of these like people that
jokopticon is like
like essentially screwing over or like
is it um
i would say that they're majority so
okay several years ago i was at
crowdconf and i heard from a product
manager
mechanical turk that your copticon had
made it so that there's a best practice
among requesters so that when they're
new they should just approve a lot
so that they build up a reputation and
then if they
are going to screw up then screw up in a
more timid way so you could say that
screwing them over or you could say that
that's just making them extremely
cautious
at what still remains a fairly low cost
there are
some tainterk has a blog
i think i skipped that slide where he um
it's a tips for requesters on
mechanicalturk.blogspot.com
so he actually publishes best practices
for requesters there are efforts to
educate requesters within this
as well but i don't
i think the fact is if you're in an
incentive structure
whether you're a graduate student or a
faculty member or
a high-tech worker where producing more
and scaling
up is the thing that's valued the thing
that's invested in the thing that's
rewarded
then relying on goodwill uh
is uh it would be an open question
whether a good will makes a significant
dent in the wages and work conditions
here and if somebody can do that
research project and show that that
is the case they would make a whole
bunch of political economists
uh they would make a breakthrough in a
political economy
but i would love to see that but all the
incentives are pointing the other way
and i so i'm coming at this as a
designer and an ethnographer
so i'm cluing in more to um
what can i do not as a big corporation
like i can't design the whole platform
because i don't have a way to maintain
it even maintaining trochopticon is
really tough
and there's a there's really hard to
actually sample all the workers to get a
sense of what the wages
you know are how their relationships
with different workers are in a rigorous
way
mary gray has found a way by
collaborating with requesters
um but it's something where you need
like very high access to
employers who employ large scale so
there's a lot of methodological
limitations that prevent me from taking
the kind of
overview of the system and so jakotson
is very much a project that comes in
kind of from the side
and tries to change how a real world
system works without being in it
so i'm curious to know more about
amazon's reaction to all this work if
you've had it
any discussions um we did meet uh sharon
chiarella who's a
director of amazon at a crowd at a crowd
meetup in san francisco in
2009 luke biewald ceo of crowdflower
actually
would put on those meetups and he
invited us to come
speak there and he was actually an early
supporter of charcoticon uh he
when we first started trekkopticon we
wanted there to be
reviews out of the box when a worker
installs it so it would be helpful so
that they would then start contributing
uh and luke helped luke and crowdflower
helped gather the initial batch of
reviews the wine system
the system so i want to credit him with
that first but amazon
doesn't seem to they basically don't
mention us
um they i believe that they own
tricopticon.com and it points to
a web page that has random ads on it
and um so they're who knows
who knows how they feel and that's
yeah that's from what i've heard from
people who used to work on that team at
amazon
this is a kind of small experimental
project it doesn't have a lot of
resources
and that explains that is what they used
to explain some of the limitations in
amazon's innovations on the worker
experience side
but if you also look at how amazon runs
its warehouses and its general
employment policies is somewhat well
known in high tech for
attempting to drive great great
efficiencies out of its workforce at
many different levels
so knows
yeah michael oh and i'll call indians
one of the reasons i think this is
important
and hard is i in a sense view mechanical
turk
as an early diviner of
what what may come in the sense of
okay mechanical turk is low cost
uh anyone can do things but looking
forward you see
in a sense the the the same effect
happening at
for professionals you look at systems
like top code or you look at systems
like
like elance odesk and we're seeing a
world where
in the utopian view you end up
i can work on whatever i want i can
i have control over my own career i can
become the ultimate freelancer
and then the dystopian view ends up
saying
i end up exploited by mediated by
requesting through a mediated channel um
and given that i feel i feel like we're
facing that
down tunnel in like some number of years
that that's somewhere between
six months in like 10 years and i'm
wondering
if given your experience there are
things you think we can do
now to guide us more towards a utopian
outcome than the dystopian one
that's really interesting way of framing
the question so i would as you were
talking about the utopian outcomes and
the dystopian outcomes like am i being
exploited or am i being empowered
i think one of the things that um one of
the ways that i look at this
is less about well actually it's not at
all clear from the way i've given the
talk right
but to me one of the key questions is
okay what kinds of people
are we becoming and what kinds of labor
relations are becoming conventional and
what are their properties like what do
they afford and what
kinds of pressures or vulnerabilities or
risks do they produce
um and so
in terms of what we can change right now
there are so many areas of research
that i would do differently looking at
it through this lens like
instead of thinking about human
computation as a kind of new management
science
that is primarily allied with the kind
of top
level administrators and how they can
manage
workforces more efficiently i would ask
of what
are forms of
cooperative or cooperative organization
like gilbert actually brought this up in
an email conversation we had
a year ago you know what would it look
like to actually organize a micro labor
sort of
cooperative and what kind of software
would need it be needed to allow for
governance and for the distribution of
payments like if i
or okay if i'm a requester and i want a
profit share
on something that i make on mechanical
turk i have no idea how to do that do i
i think i would have to have all the
requester ids and then go and take the
money
that i make off of this item and then
would have to distribute bonuses to
those workers if they even have the same
accounts that they had before
but you know these things are hard and
these are not the things that we're
building to make it easy to organize
thing in a just
way kind of out of the computational box
so like that's an example of a kind of
platform that i feel like
shifting a focus um to a just kind of
distribution of labor would
bring our attention to um i think part
of it is also actually a problem of
the way we think about where change and
value comes from
this is sort of what i was referencing
in the way that journalists kept coming
to
church opticon and saying you guys are
really saving the workers
with your technology if someone had the
headline unions 2.0
um but our union 2.0 wouldn't work if
there wasn't
all these moderators if the workers
weren't actually writing reviews for the
thing if there weren't these other
forums where workers were
giving each other the other kinds of
support they needed um
to teach each other how to be workers
and that's to tell each other about jerk
opticon
that kind of thing um so and i think
that's built into the way we value
intellectual property
and patents because patents say if you
planned it and you kind of implement it
then now you have some kind of property
ownership because merely implementing it
is not a big deal
i think that's built into some of the
ways we talk about entrepreneurship and
really focusing on the personal
qualities of the entrepreneur and their
chutzpah to implement
but we don't pay very much attention at
all to the long-term sustainability of
those enterprises
or the way value gets distributed within
so that's that's where i'd point for
like larger scale kind of research
agenda questions too like how we even
frame innovation
thanks for that yeah hi
turk is a very would you say
commoditized system
of allocating labor uh and compared to
say odesk or
something that's more specialized um do
you see that
uh like the odesse worker has more
leverage and therefore is less likely to
organize
or uh to be honest i have no experience
with odesk
um but as i understand it odesk workers
are more skilled and so they're in a
more limited supply and they tend to
work on longer term projects
that really benefit from having a bit of
a kind of collaborative relationship
with the employer
a mechanical turk is kind of the
opposite of that in which a good
well-designed mechanical turk task
is a task that can be done by whoever
might land on your task
so it's a broad it's a skill that's in
broad distribution and
you don't know if the worker's going to
be good and so you need ways to quality
check
and you kind of treat workers like a
security threat in addition to a source
of value so
because of the sort of the level of
skill amazon mechanical turk tries to
make
widely distributable um my guests from
talking to people who studied odesk is
that
the social dynamics look really
different but yeah it's a good question
i'm sorry i don't have the answer
yeah sort of similar but uh expanding
the scope slightly it seems that there's
a lot of
services now which we might not even
call crowd work
but you know um uber and lyft
are two um i know of other people who've
done copywriting
taskrabbit of course i have a friend
who's
crowdsourcing in a sense economic
indicators by having people in shenzhen
take pictures of produce
to figure out what prices are um this is
like the
cost of a week's worth of food around
the world that kind of thing
yeah exactly because a lot of those
governments don't
produce very reliable econometrics and
certainly not so granular
or rapid but
it seems like there's a lot of movement
out of sort of completely generic
uh labor markets and into more
specialized ones
and i was wondering if you've looked at
any of that at all
or have any thoughts about how that
changes
uh the story sound from the mechanical
turk
story i think that
the mechanical turk story that i've told
is most so i think of it as a kind of
sensitizing lens right i don't want to
speak for all crowd sourcing because
what's a crowdsourcing enterprise it's
sort of anything that involves large
numbers of people that someone finds
it benefits them to call crowdsourcing
maybe because it attracts venture
capital or whatever
um but i think the mechanical turk story
i'm telling you the sensitizing lens for
looking at
organizations in tech that rely on
really different valued kinds of labor
um
where some you know the people at the
upper levels
have an incentive to want to get rid of
that so like lift doesn't feel like that
kind of
labor where oh man you know driving is
such a low value activity if i hire a
lyft person i can
you know write all my books during that
time you know like lift
the lift story seems like it's more
about
adding a lot more supply to the
transportation market
um and trying to treat that like a gift
and managing the affective relations
between the driver and the passenger so
that everyone feels like it's kind of
sharing
but it's actually there's a donation
that's expected and
so i think that opens up a whole bunch
of different kinds of issues the
mechanical turk on the affective
emotional side is interesting in that
people use mechanical turk workers to do
emotional or what is it like um
sentiment analysis like let's analyze
all the tweets and find out if people
are angry
for our brand but you don't actually
care about the worker emotions you care
about the emotions and the tweets
but you need workers who have an
emotional processing kind of
a kind of an emotional literacy for the
text so they can produce that as data so
these systems
are these interfaces are sometimes about
sort of cutting down the interaction to
just the parts that
suggest the parts that matter and i
guess then the question becomes
by cutting it down to just the parts
that matter
are you cutting out all the ex all the
unjust externalities
or are you just creating a space where
it's actually really flexible
um so that's where the political economy
kind of comes into view
but um
yeah it's a good question it's not like
i have an answer for it so i'm just
trying to think it through with you yeah
so uh i'm starting to you know in real
time kind of develop this high policy is
about
a mechanical term and it seems to me
that uh
as you said it sort of puts an api in
front of a worker
and removes the diversity of the work
that they can produce
right so at the end of your second
analysis task you give
positive negative neutral right that's
your
contribution as a human being right and
it seems to me that if you
turn this around and then say well if we
want to embrace and celebrate the
diversity and
then we could create say a marketplace
which looks somewhat like etsy
you know but uh you know it's for skills
rather than
i i wonder if you and the problem there
is how does a requester
figure out how to recruit from the
school of really diverse skills
so uh i wonder if you have any thoughts
on
how that side of the equation could look
so it seems like and we really
understand your question is
um why do we have a limitation of what
we imagine wanting to make possible
through crowdsourcing
and can we imagine more interesting
outcomes than we could have
um i think one of the reasons why that's
hard is because
sometimes in my experience
you know when i was coming out of
computer science i had very little
exposure to
the complexities of being a tech writer
or of being a photographer i mean
there's a lot of
or even being a cook or a child
caregiver you know like you learn that
code is this virtuosic thing
and um so part of the paucity of
imagination might be a paucity of sort
of the disciplinary trainings that a lot
of people who are using those systems
might come into it
uh with and then part of it we were
talking newfound michael and i were
talking about why is it that none of the
crowd workers you just
crowd sourcing like the mechanical turk
is designed
if for the kinds of data processing
tasks the programmers that amazon had
um and now lots of people can use it um
but so the people that are doing
designing these platforms are not at all
the people
are people who are already kind of come
through a very limited pipeline and
gateway
so i'm not sure that might be part of
the reason why it's hard
i don't know off the top of my head
right now like
we could but i think one of the things
that's interesting about your work for
example with moocs
moocs are very controversial when people
get scared that
it means they're going to teach 150 000
students to get a stamp from a
prestigious institution
and then all the kinds of face-to-face
learning experiences that other
educational institutions are providing
will be devalued because you just want
to get a stanford certificate
but a lot of your work is about making
actual peer evaluation something that's
viable and well supported so that
actually more people can give
students that kind of thick learning
experience so i think
maybe you should tell us how to imagine
um giving the crowd a sense of richness
in productivity as opposed to an
extraction of
value or broadcasting education out
thanks for your work um okay michael's
looking kind of like how are you on time
oh okay yeah so like
the first you've taken with like it
seems like very much optimized towards
like
maximizing um like income
for the for the worker but like a lot of
workers like
the motivations it's like diverse right
like some of them are like
money a lot of others are like they do
it because it's like enjoyable
slash uh fun and interesting right
um uh
like and they don't need the money uh
yeah yeah yeah
um so like had there been any like kind
of
uh work on like evaluating like how like
fun
and interesting the um tasks that like
uh
your requesters have posted are um
i know that people have written about
needing to be concerned about what
workers motivations are i mean this is
the paper that you wrote with nikki
couture and john horton and a lot of
folks
looking at worker motivations how do you
make more tasks fun so i think that
people are concerned with that
it's not actually clear to me that the
majority of workers right now are doing
it for fun
like sort of and i'll say anecdotally
slash ethnographically because all i
know is what i know from the work people
i work with the moderators the forum
posts i read
on turkar nation i don't know anybody
who just does it for fun
they might do it because it's more fun
than driving out to the next town to get
a part-time job
but um the days when it if
so six silver my collaborator was doing
some number crunching and i can't
retrace the logic for
it now but his sense was that maybe like
a very small proportion of the work gets
done by the people who
might be doing it for fun or doing it
once in a while and the bulk of the work
gets done by people who are doing it
kind of
pretty much professionally um i don't
know if that drives with
your intuitions take mechanical turk and
subtract all of the income
do you think those people would still be
there yeah and i think the answer is
where people look at you know fair trade
and so on and that movement it's focused
on the leaders but also kind of brands
and also
focus on the employers so i'm curious
has urban studies of you know you
mentioned linkedin
but it's very kind of an institutional
effort to kind of rank
the workers that kind of understands you
know how do these different employers
use their cloud labor practices like am
i raising awareness
on that level and you know the way to
opticon is sort of
a yelp for employers actually right
because it gathers reviews of employers
that's actually the focus of it
um there
i think the project nilufer has been
heading up
we'll let work will hopefully support
workers
in taking on some of those tactics um
so when you say in the food movement
they focus on brands do you mean
focusing on brands of employers
as a tactic to leverage to pressure
those employers to have better
practices ah yeah organizational level
not the individual
level but sort of like oh all these
professors come from this company and
this company has this price
oh yeah no that's a good question i mean
that's the kind of thing where as an
academic it also
gets into a little bit of a dangerous
territory right like this academic is
encouraging a boycott of this exact
company or whatever so
um i think that there might be an
institutional issue about where this
research comes from
and no my focus has not been to sort of
lead boycotts of particular companies
but
um you can use the question of why
hasn't that come up from a
from a grassroots level and ask well
what kinds of infrastructures
are missing or is that the wrong answer
to the problem and uh
you know among other kinds of actors in
this ecology like people outside
workers other interested allies
it's a little more complicated because
you're not encouraging broadcast but you
and i are both working on software that
are successful
would mediate and support boycotts yeah
so i think this is just another example
of like the mediation like removing us
from responsibility or what's exactly
going on here
yeah um
there's a guy named ricardo dominguez at
ucsd who made an app
that was meant to um
kind of be accompany migrants crossing
the borders from mexico to california
and the app would map out where there's
water that's been placed by activists
who want to support
these these migrants and it also would
you know have bits of poetry you could
read to kind of
give you hope along the way i'm not even
sure this app
worked it was a demo but ricardo
dominguez's tenured facul
is a tenured faculty at cali t2 and was
tenured at the time and politicians in
san diego made his project into a huge
issue came after him there were
investigations
trying to assess how much research money
went into that because it seemed like
two political
um the two political and application and
so
the reality is that we're not doing this
research as thinkers sitting
you know sitting in a pasture at a
critical distance
but we are we are responsible parties
we're accountable
um and we have to make choices
about which accountabilities are worth
it
or which um kind of which risks are
worth it and which risks are not
you know so ricardo dominguez's story
has been really instructive for me and
that
there are there are people who are in a
more powerful position
to kind of lead the charge on that sort
of thing but
as somebody who's sitting in academia i
would rather
do the soft the sort of slightly soft
softer spoken thing of like well we're
making this platform
and if you all think that it's
worthwhile i'll take the responsibility
for designing the platform and for
imagining the possibility that the
platform might
suggest such a thing but um unless i
have tenure it seems
insane to say no you should go
after that particular person who may
have really powerful lawyers to go up
against my university's really powerful
lawyers
i think that's key actually when we talk
about kai research and the futures we
design and the features that we don't
we need to be talking about this
institutional these institutional kinds
of accountabilities and risks that are
shaping our research agendas because we
pretend it's all about the user
but it's not only so there's actually an
alt kai paper that's about
that um called anarchi by some folks
from the uk
this is my pitch but it just scratches
the surface
so
you